[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين ومستمعين الدوليه كما نرحب
بضيوف البرنامج الذين تشاهدونهم معي على
الشاشه يمكنكم التفاعلوا مع ما يقولون على
صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج على
تويتر كالعاده نقاشنا عن اوكرانيا من
زاويه الزياره التي يجريها الرئيس
الاوكراني الى واشنطن بعد ان زارا نيويورك
يجري مباحثات مع بايدن التقى نوابا
ومسؤولين في البونتاجون رئيس مجلس النوابل
امريكي كيفن قال انه سيطلب منزلنسكي اين
ذهبت الاموال التي استلمها من الولايات
المتحده سنحاول ان نفهم ما هي حدود الدعم
الامريكي الذي يريد سلاحا جويا ما هي ابرز
القراءات لموقف بولندا التي قررت وقف
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح الى اي حد بدا
يندثر دعم الحلفاء لاوكرانيا سعيد بان
يكون معي في الاستوديو طارق وهبي ومحلل
سياسي سعيد بان تكون من واشنطن مروه مزيد
مروه مزيد استاذ زائر في العلاقات الدوليه
في جامعه ماريلاند وسعيد بان يكون معنا من
وارسو وسيم ابو حسن ومدير موقع بولندا
بالعربي اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع
الى مقاله رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي وهو ينتقد روسيا بشده
عند عناصر جديده نقوم من خلالها بالمساءله
بخصوص المساعدات التي نقدمها لاوكرانيا
الشعب الامريكي يريد ذلك انظروا الى اخطاء
روسيا
انفقنا عبر التاريخ تريليونات الدولارات
خلال حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي والان مع
بوتين
لا يوجد امريكيون على الارض ونحن نؤمن
بالدفاع عن الديمقراطيه وسنستمر في القيام
بذلك
تحتاج الى اجابات واضحه على حد قوله
قلتها منذ البدايه اؤمن دائما بالمساءله
عن اي شيء ينفق عليه دافع الضرائب اريد
التخطيط لتحقيق النصر لذا ساستمع الى
الراي العام الامريكي ساتابع ما يحدث في
الكونجرس لدي ولد الاعضاء الاخرين اسئله
للرئيس جيلينسكي
اذهب معك مروه مزيد يعني ما يقولهما كارثي
يعكس ذهنيه بعض الامريكيين اين ذهبت
الاموال اين ذهبت الاسلحه اين وصلت هذه كل
هذه المساعدات
الله اكبر يعكس هذه الاسئله التي تبدو
وكانها يعني مثلا
تسال الان ولكن هذا ليس صحيح يعني حتى
التوجه السياسي نفسه كسياسه خارجيه لهذه
الاداره الامريكيه كان من الاول خالص في
انتقادات يمكن لم تكن معلنه جدا او مسلط
عليها الاضواء ولكن بعد سنه واثنين طبعا
بقى هذا الصوت عالي بما يكفي
لدرجه ان مكارسي يمثلوا
ويسائل
الرئيسكي ويسائل رئيس الامريكي رئيس
الولايات المتحده نفسه ما هي الخطه ما هي
السياسه لماذا هذا الدعم الذي لم يفضي الى
نتيجه ملموسه اذا الاسئله ليست مواجهه فقط
ولكن لمن
دعموا في هذه السياسه منذ اللحظه الاولى
تركوها بدا يدرك ذلك مع انه هو مقرن العزم
على المطالبه بالمزيد من الاسلحه وخاصه
الاسلحه الجويه
ما يريده من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واضح ولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي تستعمل
اوكرانيا كمنصه حقيقيه لماذا
لاحراج لاحراج روسيا في هذا الموضوع
بالتحديد الرئيس بوتين المشكله الان
انا اعتقادي هي ليست مع الجمهوريين
الجمهوريين في يوم من الايام سيعرف جيدا
ان ما قام به الرئيس بايدن لو كان رئيس
جمهوري لكان قام بنفس الموضوع لان العداء
لروسيا ليس متواجد حتى ترامب خلينا نسمع
خلينا نسمع شوي
اراد ان يكون بفنلندا لقاء مع بوتين وماذا
خرج من هذا من هذا اللقاء قال ان بوتين هو
قاتل ليس ليس هذا كلام ترامب
ضيفتك من واشنطن غير موافقه مش مشكله
المشكله هو انه لماذا نحن الان امام هذا
الموضوع هذه الاموال التي تعطيها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي اموال مهمه اساسيه
لتكمله الحرب مهمه واساسيه لدعم اوكرانيا
المشكله الان هي موقف من هي موقف بولندا
وموقف بولندا هو مبني على اساس انتخابات
ستحصل في اكتوبر والان هناك صراع سياسي
سياسي داخل بولندا في هذا الموضوع وليس
هناك اي صراع له علاقه بموضوع السياسه بما
تقره واشنطن في هذا الموضوع لذلك انا
برايي الان نحن امام الى اي مدى نستطيع ان
نعطي هذه الاموال من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لانه يا عزيزي توفيق الان نحن
امام مشكله كبرى كل الدول التي كانت في
المعسكر السوفياتي السابق
الاسلحه التي كانت سوفييتيه او الروسيه
ستنتهي كل الاسلحه القادمه هي اسلحه
بالتحديد قادمه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وانا برايي الاداره الحاليه
التي هي اداره
ديمقراطيه تعرف جيدا ان رغم ما تقوله يعني
الممثلين ويقولون الممثلين في في الحزب
الجمهوري الكل ماضي في هذه الحرب والكل
يريد ان يكمل في هذه الحرب طيب ما انك
تحدثت عن بولندا نذهب الى وارسو مع وسيم
ابو حسن يعني ما الذي حصل مع رئيس الوزراء
في بولندا حتى يتحدث بهذه الطريقه ويتكلم
بهذه الطريقه ولو انه تراجع نسبيا اليوم
اقول لا نحن سنلتزم وسنفي بما بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه خاصه بالنسبه لما طلب
منذ فتره اذا فيه اشكال معين هل هي بالفعل
نوايا انتخابيه قبل كل شيء
نعم مساء الخير للضيوف الكرام والساده
المشاهدين نعم اتفق مع الضيف الكريم
الموجود في الاستوديو بولندا قبل يعني قبل
عشرين يوم فقط من الانتخابات والحمله
الانتخابيه حاليا متصاعده بشكل مستمر وسط
خلافات كبيره بين الحزب الحاكم وايضا
المعارضه البولنديه والحزب الحاكم اليوم
متراجع في استطلاعات الرئيسه احاول الضغط
باي طريقه لتعديل هذه النتيجه قال في
الحقيقه بشكل
خلافات بين بولندا واوكرانيا ربما معظمها
لا يظهر للعلن لكنها مستمره ربما اخرها
كان المشكله بخصوص المجلس التي وقعت في
كاتين في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وطلب بولندا من الجانب الاوكراني الاعتذار
اليوم المشكله هي مشكله الحبوب او تصدير
الحبوب التي سوف التي ترغب اوكرانيا على
الاقل في تصديرها الى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي من بينها دول شرق اوروبا وهو ما
خلق يعني في البدايه عندما كانت تصل هذه
الحبوب الى السوق البولنديه كانت تؤثر
بشكل مباشر على المزارعين البولنديين
والمزارعين البولنديين هم الجمهور الاكبر
للتحالف اليميني الحاكم اليوم فكان لا بد
من الحكومه من موقف حازم سريع للرد على
رفع الحظر الذي اعلنت عنه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وتطمين المجتمع البولندي
وتحديدا المزارعين بان بولندا سوف تقوم
بحمايتهم وسوف لن تصبح وصول هذه الحبوب ما
ما يمكن ان نقوله حاليا بان الموضوع هو
مستخدم بشكل اكبر في الراي او في المجتمع
البولندي عنه في
موجه لاوكرانيا فكما تفضلت يعني وزير رئيس
الوزراء ماتش اعلن اليوم بان جميع العقود
الموقعه مع اوكرانيا سوف يستمر تصديرها
بشكل كامل والجديد والجديد وانت تتحدث
الان هو الرئيس البولندي الذي صحح كلام
رئيس وزراء والخبر نزل للتو اننا سنزود
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من السلاح وان
رئيس وزرائه لم يفهم جيدا كلام يعني
في ضغط امريكي اكيد لا
صحيح صحيح وايضا حتى وزاره المصادر في
وزاره الخارجيه قالت ان تصريح مورافيتسكي
لم يكن بالتنسيق معها بل تفاجات وزاره
الخارجيه واستغرقت عده ساعات لتحضير الرد
وتطمين اوكرانيا بشكل خاص والمجتمع الدولي
بشكل عام بولندا مستمره في دعم اوكرانيا
وسوف تستمر في تصويريات السلاح وربما اضيف
نقطه اخيره بان العداء بين الحزب الحاكم
اليوم وروسيا ليس عداء بصفه فقط بسبب
الحرب الاوكرانيه زعيم الحزب الحاكم في
بولندا هو شقيق لخكتشينسكي الرئيس
البولندي الذي سقطت طائرته في مدينه
سمولينك الروسيه والتي حتى اليوم بولندا
تتهم فيها روسيا بانها هي من قامت الاسقاط
فالعداء تاريخي وحتى مع وجود خلافات مع
اوكرانيا فان الدعم البولندي سوف يبقى
مستمر يعني التغير الوحيد الذي يمكن ان
يحصل هو خساره الحزب الحاكم في الانتخابات
طيب مروه مزيد عفوا قلت مزيد اننا اعتدنا
على المزيد من الاخبار والمزيد من كذا
والمزيد بالتاكيد
حصل ضغط امريكي لانه ليس من صالح اداره
بايدن في هذا الظرف ان يحصل شرخ بين
شريكين وحليفين ان ياتي الرئيس ويقول
والله رئيس وزراء لا لم يفهم جيدا كلام
يعني هذه طريقه امريكيه له
هو قطعا يعني الاداره الامريكيه ستضغط
وهذا يعني وارد لكن انا عايزه اصحح حاجه
مهمه جدا قالها انه سواء الجمهوريين او
الديمقراطيين لو رئيس جمهوري في هذا الظرف
لا هو ترامب كان مثلا محدد نفسه جدا انه
بيقول انه هذه الحرب
ما كانت لتحدث لو كنت انا رئيس
يا سيدتي وليست نظريها وجهه نظر ولا
تستطيع ان تبني على وجهه نظر رجل عليه
الان عده محاكم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
الحوار الان وتلاقيه في كلام مكارسي انه
هو فكره ان انا لا لازم نلتفت بقى اذا
الاموال تم صرفها بعنايه ولا لا وانا
ادافع عن مواطن لان هو اللي من يمول هذا
كل ده في خطاب داخلي له علاقه بالانتخابات
طبعا الامريكيه القادمه من سيكون المرشح
الجمهوري وفي ماركيشن الان يعني
الجمهوريين
يحدده انفسهم الان انهم مختلفين الان الى
حد ما على الاقل في هذه السياسه الخارجيه
ففكره انه ترامب كان قد بالفعل قال طبعا
وهو لا يمكن كانت الحرب دي تحدث لو كان هو
رئيسا هو باقي الجمهوريين سياخذوا من هذا
الغزل سواء هم يدعموني او لا
ليه ليه فكره ان هم سياستهم الخارجيه
مختلفه عن هذه الاداره الفاشله من وجهه
نظر التقطير له هل يعني هذا انهم لم
الجمهوريين يعني
خلف الدعم ودفع كل هذه المليارات لا طبعا
دفعوا وهناك يعني
انتصر
سياسيه
بيزنس مع الدفاع ده جزء اصيل منه
الجمهوريين ولكن انا اوضح انه الان في هذا
المنعطف قبل الانتخابات يعني تمهيدا لها
لا الجمهورين عايزين يميزوا ما بين اذا
كان جمهوريين في الحكم او الجمهوري تحديدا
ترامب او هم كجمهوريين بنزله من هذا
المنعطفه مختلفه كانوا بيسالوا بشكل مختلف
كان الحصاد هيبقى شيء مختلف وبالتالي لما
ارجع تاني لنقطتي الاولى في اعاده النظر
للسياسه نفسها اه طبعا الجمهورين من هنا
ورايح يعني يؤكدها على هذا وكمان لاحظ ان
الشومر اللي هو بقى يعني في السنه مش في
مجلس النواب وهو ديمقراطي اخر جمله في
الصحافيين هذه الصور اللي انت تعرضها
السوق ماذا تريد ماذا ستقول الا يعني ان
هم طبعا الامريكيين معنا وكذا شوم رجع
وللصحافيين وقال لهم في جمله انتم ما
سمعتوهاش انا عايزه اؤكد انه قال ان لم
يكن هناك دعما حاليا يعني دعم عسكري سنخسر
الحرب فهو طبعا من الضغط على انه اما
نموله الان الائمه سنخسر الحرب لكن هذا
تمهيدا لخساره الحرب وهذا ما سيقول
الجمهوريين انه
اداره الحاليه ربما اخسرتنا الحرب لماذا
لسوء ادارتها في هذا الملف اذا هناك يعني
تحول يعني كان الدعم الامريكي بلا حدود
بلا قيود كل هذه الفتره السابقه انا اقول
الان انه واضح جدا من هذا الخطاب انه من
الان ورايح القضيه الاوكرانيه لن يتفق
عليها الجميع كما كان الحال من سنه وسيظهر
هذا اكثر واكثر نوع من توجيه الانتقاد الى
الاداره الامريكيه والرئيس
بايرن يسمعه على منذ قليل ان الولايات
المتحده ستزود اوكرانيا
بامكانيات
تتعلق بالدفاع خاصه الدفاع الجوي
لاوكرانيا والحديث للبيت الابيض الموقف
الامريكي واضح يعني اولا يجب ان نشكر
ضيفتك المتحده الامريكيه لشرحها كل هذه
التفاصيل المبنيه على اساس سياسه سياسيه
داخليه ومتجه متجهه نحو موضوع له علاقه
بالانتخابات القادمه
وتقليل من اهميه ما يقوم به بايدن يعني
هناك عمل دائم على عراق سياسي فيما نسميه
الكره التي يقذفها الجمهوريين الى
الديمقراطيين الجمل هذه نقطه النقطه
الثانيه والمهمه بالموضوع لا احد لا احد
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعتقد انه
يجب وقف للدعم لاوكرانيا لماذا لان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قبل ان تبدا
هذه الحرب كانت الشريكه الكبرى في بعض
المشاريع الاستثماريه داخل اوكرانيا
وخصوصا انه علمنا انه مثلا عدد من
الجنرالات الذين تركوا الجيش ومن اصول
اوكرانيه قدموا الى مناطق البحر الاسود
وبالتحديد لاوديسا لانشاء مشاريع مهمه وهم
كانوا وراء ما يسمى الدفع بالولايات
المتحده بالاداره للقول انه يجب ان نرد
على ما يقوم به
اذا الان المشكله هي مرتبطه بمفهوم
السياسه وانا انا لا اريد ان ازاهد على
كلام ترامب ترامب هذا الرجل هو يعتقد ان
الحديث الشعبوي مع الشارع الامريكي الذي
سالته اين تقع دوله تونس مثلا يقول لك في
المحيط الهندي لا يعرف هناك فقر بمفهوم
السياسه الخارجيه اللي حكيت عنها واللي
المشكله الكبرى انه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها مكتب لكل دوله في العالم
وهي تعرف ما يحصل بكل دوله لانه مصالحها
اهم من اي شيء انا برايي الان
زيلنسكي يعني يخيل لي نفس موقف ما حصل مع
ابو عمار تخيل هو يلبس كاكي يذهب الى
الامم المتحده انا غصن السلام غسل الزيتون
ذكر كلمه يونايتد 12 مره في خطابه اتحاد
لانه خائف وهون انا اوافق مع السيده في
واشنطن ان هناك من يلعب داخل
اوافق بمعنى لماذا
لا يزال داخل ما يسمى الاطار الامريكي هو
حساب من الخاسر ومن الرابح ولا تريد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تكمل بهذا
الموضوع الا لان تعرفوا اقله يكون في
عندها يعني هامش من المعرفه من ماذا سيقوم
ما هي ستكون رده بوتين في هذا الموضوع
لانه لا يمكن انا باعتقادي حاليا الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيين ان تكمل مع بايضا
بهذه الطريقه غير ممكن وان ياتي ترامب الى
الاداره ايضا غير ممكن بمعنى ان من سيستلم
هذا الملف اذا لم ياتي بايدن ولم ياتي
ترامب وهنا المشكله
وسيم ابو حسن يعني
اعفيك طبعا من كل المقالات التي كتبت بعد
الاعلان عن وقف تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
وخاصه في فرنسا ومختلف التعليقات في في
الاذاعات وفي التلفزيونات طيب اوكي هذا
الملف طوى حاليا لكن هل كان هذا سيفهم
خاصه وان بولندا كانت تقريبا هي النافذه
الاساسيه
للاوكرانيين عند بدايه الحرب وراينا ما
راينا من وصول لعدد كبير من الاوكرانيين
يعني كيف نظر البولنديون لمثل هذا التصريح
هل حصل امتعاد نوعا ما ام حصلت تساؤلات
سوء فهم
نعلق على النقطه السابقه
بولندا اليوم تراقب حزمه المساعدات التي
يناقشها الكونجرس الامريكي لاوكرانيا
وبولندا بالطبع منتظره اقرار هذه الحزمه
لانه كما قلنا الموضوع ليس مرتبط فقط
باوكرانيا بالولايات المتحده عربت باكثر
من مره بانها ملتزمه بامن الناتو يعني
خساره اوكرانيا للحرب تحمل سيناريوهين
اسواهم وصول الجيش الاوكراني الى حدود
بولندا وباقي دول شرق اوروبا السيناريو
الافضل هو وجود حكومه مواليه لموسكو في
كيف ما يعني ان هذه الحكومه سوف تخلق
المزيد من الازمات لدول شرق اوروبا وهو ما
نشرها حاليا في بيلاروسيا التي قامت بخلق
ازمه هجره هجينه لدول شرق اوروبا للضغط
عليها السياسيا والاستفاده من هذا الموضوع
فالحرب الاوكرانيه فالموضوع كما قلنا
موضوع المساعدات لا تنتظره اوكرانيا فقط
بل حتى دول شرق اوروبا بالعوده الى داخل
البولندي يعني
بالتصريحات الرسميه التي صدرت عن المس من
من راس الهرم من الرئيس البولندي وصولا
الى باقي المسؤولين ان تصريحات الرئيس
الاوكراني اعتبرها البولنديون او على
الاقل من الجانب الحكومي هي طعنه في الظهر
خصوصا وانها كما قلنا تاتي في وقت قبل
الانتخابات بعشرين يوم تصريحات زيلينسكي
كانت حاده بشكل غريب يعني وصف الدول التي
ترفض السماح للمزارعين او التجار
الاوكرانيين بتصدير الحبوب الى الاسواق
شرق دول شرق اوروبا هي دول تدعم روسيا في
مساعدتها بالنسبه لبولندا كانت التصريحات
صادمه خصوصا وانها اكبر دوله بالنسبه
للناتج المحلي قدمت مساعدات لاوكرانيا
بولندا قدمت اكثر من 350 دبابه من مخزونها
اكثر من 40 طائره من طراز مجموع المساعدات
يقدر بثلاثه مليارات يورو وهو كما قلنا
مقارنه بالناتج المحلي لبولندا فهي اكبر
دوله قدمت مساعدات للجانب الاوكراني حتى
مع الموضوع بدبلوماسيه عندي
جو لانه قرات موضوع له علاقه انه اليوم
اوكرانيا تخسر 600 مليون دولار له علاقه
بتمرير هذه الحبوب اكثر من ذلك هناك داخل
بولونيا لحمايه المزارع البولوني قيل انه
في مرحله ما هناك رجال اعمال بولييين من
بولونيا استفادوا بنقل هذه الحبوب
يعني ايصالها الى المانيا او الى هولندا
او الى فرنسا او حتى الى افريقيا ولكن عن
طريق البحر مرورا بمرافق اما في من بولوني
او مرافق المانيا ولكن المشكله الكبرى ان
البعض من هؤلاء التجار في بولونيا ماذا
فعلوا استفادوا ببيع هذه الحبوب على السوق
المحلي والتقليل من الاسعار لذلك ضربت صار
هناك مشاكل مع المزارعين اذا المشكله ايضا
داخليه في بولونيا ولكن اوافقك بالموضوع
ان الرئيس سيلانسكي لا يمكن الا ان يتحدث
بهذه الطريقه لانه يرى انه محرج كليا لم
يع تستطيع ان يستقطب القاده او الرؤساء
الا في هذه الطريقه للاسف
صحيح هو في حال مرور الحبوب من اراضيها
يجب ان تذهب الى ثالثه نعم صحيح حصلت
حالات فساد وتم وضع نظام محدد لوزن الحبوب
قبل دخولها الى بولندا ويجب وزنها ايضا في
المناطق التي سوف يتم تصدير منها سواء
كانت موانئ او معبر حدوديه لضمان عدم دخول
هذه
المطبقاء هذه الحبوب في الاراضي البولنديه
لكن كما قلنا المشكله ليست موضوع الحبوب
هو جزء من المشكله لكن المشكله الرئيسيه
تصريحات التي كما قلنا يعتبرتها الحكومه
البولنديه طعنه في الظهر خصوصا في وقت
انتخابات يعني الاشاره الى بولندا على
انها تساعد روسيا في هذه الحرب عبر منع
تصدير حبوب طعمه كبيره لبولندا التي كما
كنا قدمت المساعده الاكبر هي كانت طريق
العبور من اللحظه الاولى اول مسؤول اساسا
زارا كيف بعد بدايه الغزو كان من بولندا
باول تحرك سياسي كان من بولندا بزياره
مولافيتسكي لالمانيا للطلب المساعدات
العسكريه فبولندا قدمت كل ما تستطيع هي
مستمره في ذلك النقطه الثانيه هي ان
الشارع البولندي بغض النظر ايضا عن موضوع
الحبوب تحملت الجزء الاكبر من الاعباء
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه لهذه الحرب بولندا
اليوم تستضيف اكثر من مليون و600 الف لاجئ
اوكراني التضخم في بولندا اكبر من باقي
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي فرص العمل يوم
الاوكرانيين سمح تم السماح لهم بشكل مباشر
بالدخول في سوق العمل في التعليم في
الطبابه الصحيه تحملت الجزء الاكبر فبعد
كل ما قدمته بولندا للجانب الاوكراني
وتصدر هذه التصريحات بالطبع المجتمع بشكل
عام والحكومه بشكل خاص كانت مصدومه وكان
لابد لها من الرد بشكل نوع فقط على هذه
التصريحات طيب مروه اراك وانت تقولين لا
يعني
يعني اولا فعلا هو التشبيه بفكره
عرفات مثير الى حد ما لانه فكره انه يعني
ضيفك اللي بيوصف بولندا وفكره الضيق من من
التصريحات اللي هي زائده عن الحد فكره انه
احنا عملنا لك كثير وماذا انت حتى قدمت
يعني فكره
بتكتب في انه انه فكره ان الحشد لدعم جديد
في حين ان الهجوم المضاده اللي قامت به
اوكرانيا لم يحقق تقدم كبير ففي الاخر كل
الدول اللي هي داعمه لاوكرانيا عايزه
نتائج محدده وعايزه تدعم الناجح فهذا
زيلينسكي قادم لواشنطن ثم يعني يحتك
بتصريحات
لبولندا فهذا يعكس اصلا ان هو متوتر مضطرب
لم لم يحقق النتائج يزال التصفيق له الدعم
والان يعني يقول انه بلا الدعم الحالي
سنخسر الحرب كليا فتاه تمهيد لفكره
ربما بعد التلميحات حتى من قبل بايدن نعم
سنعطيك الان مستشار في البيت الابيض يقول
لا لن نزود اوكرانيا بصواريخ طويله المدى
يعني نعطيك ربما صواريخ متوسطه او المدى
بس طويله المدى لا يعني هل انت برايك عامل
الثقه ضرب قليلا بين الشريكين
اتاكد منها ان داخل داخل الامريكي في في
ناس فاقد الثقه من الاول ولكن هذه سياسه
هذه الاداره واحنا بنشوف نهايتها ايه لكن
انا اعتقد الان مع وجود يعني نتائج
ليست بالمستوى قال حتى المرجو اطلاقا ونوع
من اننا اوكي خلينا ورا الكذاب يعني اوكي
هندي لك حزمه اخرى لكن ماذا ستفضي الى
ماذا يعني انا لا اتوقع انها ستفدي لاي
شيء
لا لا
وكذاب لحد باب
[ضحك]
يعني نعطيك ثم نرى
هو مثل هو مثل
سنعطيك لنرى ماشي انما انت ال24 مليار
دولار الحاليين هل فعلا يعني ينجحوا الحرب
هل ده المتوقع لا طبعا ليس هذا المتوقع
ولكن الولايات المتحده كمان مع تصريحه هو
ان هو اذا لم تدعميني الان سنخسر الحرب
اذا سندعمك ولكن هل تحت امريكيون يعني
متوقعين نتيجه افضل منك بس هو هو قال
ننتظر شهورا صعبه يعني خلاص في النهايه
صعبه يعني في النهايه تفيق الحرب هي خساره
او ربح يمكن في موضوع مش عم نحكي فيه هو
الى اي مدى اصبحت اليوم روسيا
رفعت من انتاجها الحربي لكي تصل الى مستوى
يفوق كل ما تقوم به هذه المساعدات
الامريكيه يعني قبل كان في مشكله اليوم
اصبح هناك مستوى تصنيع العسكري الروسي
بمستوى جد عالي بمساعده من الصين واخيرا
مساعده كوريا الشماليه
يجب ان لا ننسى ذلك انه بالنهايه
لا يحارب دوله صغيره هو لا يحارب عفوا
صديقنا من بولوديا
اوكرانيا لا تحارب بولونيا هي تحارب القوه
الثانيه في العالم من حيث التجهيز العسكري
رغم كل المشاكل التي هي موجوده لا تحارب
فقط يعني دوله صغيره تفضلي
نرجع تاني وده يعني تقييم عسكري انه
المفروض الهجوم المضاد اللي كان يحدث في
الاسبرينج في الربيع اللي بينتهي الان
احنا داخلين في الخريف كان يخرج نتائج
معينه محدده حتى نقول انه في فوز لهذه
الحرب حتى لو تغيرت الاداره الامريكيه
القياده العسكريه ستظل موجوده هذه القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه لا تغير لا تتغير
عندما يقدم الجمهوريين اذا هذه القياده
العسكريه هي التي تعطي للقائد السياسي
لاخذ قرار الموضوع هو ليس مرتبط
بالسياسيين هناك قاده عسكريين يساعدون
السياسه طيب حتى حتى اتفضلي تفضلي المدنيه
العسكريين جدا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من يسن السياسه الخارجيه هو
رئيس الجمهوريه والاداره الامريكيه
المنتخبه
الاداره المدنيه
المؤسسه العسكريه
يعني اوكي فهو يعطي كل
الاكسبرت اوبينيون او الراس
ولكن اه طبعا تتغير السياسه مع تغير مثلا
اداره او تغيير
حتى تتغير سياستها فما فيش حاجه اسمها
العسكريين ماذا اين سيذهبون حتى مع اداره
جديده كل ده ممكن يختلف ويبقى نيوانس اكتر
ودقيق اكثر وفكره المحاسبه ارجع تاني
المقرسي وهذا
الخطاب اللي انا عايزه يعني فقط كانه خيط
نتتبعه انه هتلاقي انا باتوقع لك بس من
دلوقتي لانه فعلا هو الربط بالداخل
الامريكي هتلاقي من هنا ورايح انه في فكره
انه ان الجمهوريين بيميزوا خطابهم في هذه
السياسه الخارجيه تجاه اوكرانيا ان احنا
يعني طبعا كنا لازم ندعم اوكرانيا ولكن
السياسه ومقاتها وتفاصيلها فاشله وبالتالي
نحمل هذا التحميل على الاداره الامريكيه
السياسيه مش العسكريين طبعا الامريكيين
ولا اي ولا اي حلفاء اخرين السياسه نفسها
بتفصل فانا ده اللي انا بس بلف نظر ليه
انه هناك الان حتلاقي انه لا الاجماع على
اوكرانيا بتفاصيلها يعني امر سياسي داخلي
يتباحث في الجهات الجهتين الامريكيتين
ابو حسن ربما ايضا بولندا يعني انتبه هذا
التفكير ربما ساد لدى البعض هناك دول اخرى
لم تحترم هذا الاجماع الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بالدعم
لاوكرانيا لما لا نحن ايضا والحديث طبعا
عن المجر التي ليست بعيده والحديث عن دول
اخرى يمكن ان نصيفها بانها قريبه من
بولندا
نعم كما ذكرت في البدايه لمشكله الحبوب
يمكن هي هي المشكله التي ظهرت في الاعلام
او طفت على السطح حاليا في الحديث عن
المشاكل بين بولندا واوكرانيا لكن هناك
العديد من المشاكل ليس فقط مع بولندا مع
العديد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ربما هي
مشابهه للمشكله التي تحصل حاليا بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين بعيدا عن الشق
الداخلي برغبه الجمهوريين بمحاوله تحقيق
مكاسب داخليه بالاعتراض وسمى الموافقه
بالسينار الذي خلي بالك خلي بالك يسمعك
بوتين سيكون سعيدا
لا بس يعني
في الحقيقه الموضوع ليست يعني
وجود تقارير عن فساد في القياده العسكريه
البولنديه في القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وحتى في الحكومه البولنديه هو محقير وزاره
الدفاع تم تغيير وزير الدفاع في اوكرانيا
بموضوع له علاقه باجابه
لماضي طلب من الديمقراطيين في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان هناك
وهو يعني ما هو كما قلنا يعني ما يحصل
داخل حلف الناتو هو شبيه لما يحصل في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك مطالبات
لمتابعه الدعم الذي يتم تقديمه الى
اوكرانيا الطريقه التي يتم استخدامه فيها
المكان الذي يتم استثمار هذه المساعدات
سواء كانت ماديه او عسكريه او حتى انسانيه
داخل اوكرانيا هناك يعني مشكله في متابعه
هذه المساعدات التي تصل وهو ما تم
المناقشته ربما ليس بشكل معلن ولكن كان
احد مواضيع النقاش في القمه التي عقدت في
فيلنس من فتره قريبه يعني اليه تنسيق
الاليه وايضا الاجتماع الذي حصل وكان نوعا
ما اجتماع سري يعني اعلنت عنه بعد ان
كعقاده بشهر في شهر في الشهر السادس يعني
كان هناك اجتماع بين القياده الامريكيه
وقياده حلف الناتو والقياده الامريكيه
والقياده الاوكرانيه عفوا التي حضرت وتم
تسليمها
خطوات محدده يجب اتباعها لاستمرار حصولها
على الدعم والطريقه استخدام الذخيره
والجبهات التي يجب فتحها عدد القذائف حتى
التي يمكن استخدامها بشكل يومي فكما قلنا
يعني المشكله التي تواجهها الولايات
المتحده اليوم في اقرار حزمه الدعم
الخامسه لاوكرانيا هي ايضا مشكله موجوده
لدى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي سواء كانت
بولندا او دول شرق اوروبا وحتى باقي الدول
في غرب اوروبا مراقبه طريقه مراقبه هذه
المساعدات واين يتم استخدامها لاستمرار
الدعم للمراحل المقبله يعني دخلنا في
تحاليل
هلا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كاوروبا
بمعنى انه ماذا تريد ان تجيب للمواطن على
الضرائب الذي يدفعها هذا حق
ولكن تسمع انت في اوروبا في اوروبا ايضا
اوكي الولايات المتحده بعيده كل البعد
عن الميدان وبالتالي ترسل اسلحه وتترك
اوروبا تواجه كل هذه الاشكاليه شيء طبيعي
لانه الموضوع جغرافيا موجود في اوروبا
وليس موجود في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
خلينا نقارب الموضوع من السيده ميلوني
عندما قدمت ميلوني ماذا قالت انا سادعم
اوكرانيا واكملت بالدعم وهي من اليمين
المتطرف يعني هي قريبه لوجهه نظر اوربان
بموضوع انغلاق بموضوع ان يكون هناك فقط
العمل في الوطن في الداخل لذلك انا برايي
كمان يجب ان لا ننسى ان هناك عاملات
عمليات نوعيه من الاوكران قام فيها الجيش
الاوكراني بالتحديد بجزيره القرم وبتوجيه
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا هناك
يعني للاسف الشديد نحن امام نوع من مقياس
نقيس فيه ماذا يفعل الجيش الاوكراني في
هذا الوقت اين تذهب هذه الاموال المشكله
الكبيره انه
امتداد ما نسميه الجبهه طويل جدا الولايات
المتحده والولايات المتحده الامريكيه مهما
قدمت
لدى روسيا اربعه اضعاف اكثر من ما موجود
كانت تدرك ذلك منذ البدايه نعم
الدعم اقول لك المشكله هي سياسيه سياسيه
بحته ما بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
لانه انتخابات قادمه ولا الكل يعرف جيدا
انه لا يمكن ان تربح اوكرانيا الا بدعم
امريكي هذا اذا ربحت اوكرانيا لانه دائما
في الحرب هناك خساره هناك ربح الان نحن
امام تضييق لكل ما يحصل ضد روسيا الرئيس
الروسي لم يذهب الى اجتماع العشرين قمه
العشرين لم يذهب الى البريكس والان حتى
الرئيس البرازيلي الذي قال
الاجتماع لولا سيحصل بعد الاجتماع الدول
العشرين في البرازيل تراجع عن القول انه
سيترك للقضاء الحق في اعتقال او غير عدم
اعتقال الرئيس بوتين اذا نحن امام خطوات
دوليه تساعد في تضييق الخناق على روسيا
بالمفهوم
لكن المشكله العسكريه ان روسيا بدات
بالانتاج الحربي اسرع بكثير يعني اليوم
بولونيا ستنتهي من كل ما نسميه السلاح
السوفيتي وستبدا بما نسميه سلاح اجنبي اي
سلاح غربي يعني من الولايات المتحده اذا
انت الان اذا لا يوجد هذا التصنيع العسكري
وضيفتك من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعرف جيدا القدره على ما نسميه اللي هي
موجوده
اللجنه اللجنه الدفاع الموجوده في السنه
اللي هي اقوى لجنه بموضوع البزنس وبموضوع
الشركات التي تصنع والتي اكثر من
تصدر هذه الموضوع حضرتك قلت انه لا توجد
صواريخ بعيده المدى هذا قرار استراتيجي
ليس قرار ولكن هذا هذا نقله لبعض الصحف
الامريكيه التي تحدثت ايضا بان حتى اوستن
بدا يطرح بعض الشروط فيما يتعلق يتدربناكم
زودناكم باسلحه زودناكم بكل ما تريد ماذا
تفعلون ما هو ما هي قيمه الجيش الاوكراني
اليوم بعد كل ما حصل عليه من مساعدات كلمه
بسيطه انت انت تتكلم مع جيش بشري ما عندك
روبوت ما عندك يعني كمان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يجب ان تكون واقعيه في هذا
الموضوع
مهم جدا انه بالنسبه
اللي هي الصواريخ التكتيكيه الامريكيه ان
يعني لن تذهب بعشر لانه الفكره كلها ان
الولايات المتحده تصر من اللحظه الاولى
انها بتدعم اوكرانيا في الدفاع فلا ينبغي
ابدا انها
تزودها باسلحه تبدو وكانها هجوم على روسيا
فدي هتفضل
العقبه الاولى في عشان كده عشان كده
اوكرانيا طول الوقت فكره بتلعب كاتشنج اب
هي عمرها ما كانت هتلحق انها تحقق فعلا
حاجه كبرى لانها كل شويه اصلا تطلب
محدد والولايات المتحده تتاخر لسبب انها
ما يبقاش هي بتدعمها مباشره فكل التعطيل
ده اصلا يعني سيستماتيك معروف واضح في
الخطه نفسها ان انت لا مش من اول لحظه
بديكم ابعد عنك وبالتالي كانه يعني
واضح جدا لاي حد عنده استراتيجك فرصه ان
ده هنوصل للمنعطف ده يعني هو واضح لكثيرين
الحقيقه اهم شيء انا عايزه اقوله من
الخلاصه بتاعه قصه اوكرانيا اللي خدت سنه
ونص منه بعد كوفيد فيعني كان نوع من حرب
معينه لحرب اخرى لما نشوف الحرب الثالثه
هتبقى ايه
اوكرانيا المفروض انها دراسه حاله الان في
فكره السكيوريتيكو اوبريشن اللي الولايات
المتحده بتقوم بيه مع دول مختلفه مع يعني
مش حتى حلفاء بمعنى النيتو لكن بارتنرز او
شركاء والمفروض بنقص حتى في الادبيات
العلاقات المدنيه العسكريه والعلاقات
الدوليه وكذا ان هذه الحاله حاله ناجحه
يعني زودنا
البارتنر بتاعنا الشريك ويبدو بيعمل بلاء
حسنا وهو ده وعندهم الشجاعه وعندهم كل ده
اعتقد ان ده مهم جدا ان الوقت هذه الحاله
بمظاهر بعض الفشل على الاقل فيها
والتمك اذا فشلت هي هتبين انه لا في
سكيورتي بارتنرز للولايات المتحده مثل
اوكرانيا يتورطون جدا تتحول بلادهم
لبروكسي وور وحرب بالوكاله وكل هذا ثم
يفشلوا برده لان هم طبعا حجمهم صغير ولا
ويعني بالنسبه
وبالتالي يعني كيف سنقر بهذا من يسمعك
يعني كان المفروض نترك بوتين يوصل لكيف
لا هو في وجهه نظر تانيه ان هو ما كانش
المفروض وبعدين طب ما هو صبح له على يد
برده اوباما ان هو ياخد لكن هو لا المفروض
لا يسمح له انه يتخيل ان هو من التهديد
بمكان ان هو يتحول الى هو عايز يعمل
البافر الزون دي بنفسه فهذه وجهه نظر اخرى
يعني
انت تدعم الدوله لكي تقف ضد روسيا وبنفس
الوقت لا تستطيع ان تتركيها امام بغول
كروسيا يعني غير ممكن فعليا انا شخصيا
شايفه ان تاريخيا هيبقى فعليا ده اللي حصل
حضرتك بتكانك عم تعملي لحتى نعمل له علاقه
بمفهوم التوازن هذا الحرب وكيفيه العمل
فيه نحن الان بحرب علينا ان نجد حلول انا
هذا رايي
طيب بولندا يمكن ان تقدم الحل بعد هذا
الموقف الذي تراجع نسبيا
يعني كما قلنا بولندا
يمكن اثر دوله تراقب ما يحصل في اوكرانيا
كم يعني اليوم الولايات
التزامها بتعهداتها في حمايه حلف الناتو
وايضا الحرب الاوكرانيه كما قلنا لا تؤثر
على اوكرانيا فقط تؤثر على حلف الناتو
بشكل عام
يعني
الغريب في الامر عندما جرى الحديث عن الاف
16 من بين الدول التي عرضت عن استعدادها
لتزويد اوكراني بنفس التاجر بولندا
حكومه مواليه لموسكو لقياده اوكرانيا
المقاربه الامريكيه محكوم عليها بان لا
تتغير في الظرف الحالي اكيد لا يمكن ان
تتغير المقاربه الامريكيه لطالما
توجد قوه لدى بوتين في هذا يعني يجب ان
تسقط فكره ان بوتين يستطيع ان يربح هذه
الحرب اقله هناك من يبحث عن نوع من طرح
جديد له علاقه بنوع من فيدراليه للاقاليم
الاربعه التي استعدته انا اقرا عده عده
يعني من تحت الامريكيه حتى الالمان او حتى
في بولندا بولندا الرئيس الامريكي ذهب
بزياره رسميه الى بولندا غير كل الدول
وقال له سندعمكم ماليا واعطاهم فلوس
اعطاهم اموال دعم مالي اجى على بولندا
وقال اكثر من ذلك ساضع لكم قبه حديديه لها
علاقه بصواريخ تحميكم من الصواريخ النوويه
وهذا لازم يقوله فقط بايدن قاله ايضا
بلينكين يعني بمعنى انه لا يمكن في
المقاربه الامريكيه الا ان تسير في هذا
الموضوع واذا خطر ببال الجمهوريين ان
يقفوا ويضعوا مددهم مع بوتين انا برايي
سيكون هناك خراب لما نسميه القوه العسكريه
الحاكمه في العالم يعني
هذا الكلام وهو واقف امام عدد كبير من
الجمهور وطبعا وقف ولكن بشكل بشكل جيد
الشكر في الختام لتركها ومحلل لسياسي شكر
من واشنطن لمروه مسجد وليس مزيد مثل ما
قلته سهوا استاذ زاهر في العلاقات الدوريه
في جامعه ميريلاند وشكرا لوسيم ابو حسن
مدير موقع بولندا بالعربي الشكر لفريق
البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]
1966 سيناريو لا يصدق ومنسي الى حد بعيد
صدام طائرتين طبيعتين لسلاح الجو الامريكي
فوق سماء بالوماراس في اسبانيا احداهما
قذيفه نوويه علمتنها اربع قنابل ذريه غير
معده للانفجار لكن اثنتين منهما دمر
تاجراء اصطدامهما بالارض ما تسبب في تسرب
اشعاعي شبح البروتونيوم يهدد الصحه
والنظام البيئي عثر على القنبله الثالثه
سليمه بينما تطلب العثور على القنبله
الرابعه في قاع البحر 89 يوما من التوتر
الشديد افادات مؤثره لسكان ما زالوا
يبحثون عن اجوبه ولخبراء ينددون بغموض
الحكومه والجيش الامريكيين تذكره عوده الى
بالون ماريس على فرانزانتات دوت كوم